this is it can't believe it  it's our final hit  come on you  let's go to cat's party soft launch  don't say soft launch  god i completely forgot  what do we do for a living we definitely  don't kill people for a living we work  in security exactly get in here are you  all right with that thing i think now  i'm pretty excited  if someone's got something you want you  need to take control of the situation  you need to forget about fran and move  on you've got me now  and i'm not going anywhere you ready  showtime  [Music]  bloody hell  [Music]  bring them to me  i love you i love you too should we kiss  them but you have to make everything so  weird  [Music]  never never mess with a funky fresh  you